well this is how it must look because
we've always done it this way so I'm
sure there were some experts back here
at some point right that developed like
this is what human development needs
there were experts but they were experts
on how to break a human system because
this Prussian system designed for Mass
obedience in the times of the Industrial
Revolution the most damaging part of a
conveyor belt school system is that we
are teaching the young people they are
not to be trusted you are only allowed
to really speak to for the majority of
the day people of your own data
manufacturer if I'm six I'm only around
other six-year-olds I'm going to stand
in my straight line I'm going to raise
my hand and ask permission for anything
and everything for years on end
including I'm going to ask another human
being even though I'm 18. if I can go to
the bathroom I'm learning to be blindly
obedient to anybody who claims to be an
authority this is your assignment this
is what you're going to do if you obey
well I'll give you an a if you go
outside the box on this you're not going
to get the arbitrary letter grade that
I'm going to give you okay sounds good
I'm working on it ding Bell Rings move
on to the next part of the conveyor belt
whether you're enjoying what you're
doing or not it doesn't matter right
it's this Industrial Revolution model
based on authoritarianism that builds
that mindset into the young Heroes you
leave there going I don't know anything
about me but I know how to obey I know
how to follow directions tell me what to
somebody tell me what to do next and
there's this old saying it's like a
bird's born in a cage thing flying is an
illness the last 150 years or so has
been this social experiment of schooling
and so what happens for a lot of parents
too is they even if they see this from
an intellectual standpoint and they try
to leave they fly out of the cage
there's still this emotional tie to what
everybody else is doing and what they've
already known
foreign that was Matt Boudreau
provocative thought leader in
educational and personal development
practices he's a two-time featured tedx
speaker and was named corporate trainer
of the year at Stanford University with
an extensive qualification list he not
only has been both a public and private
school teacher and administrator he's
also a keynote speaker consultant and
Coach to organizations around the world
with clients who have ranged from Wells
Fargo and Honeywell to American Eagle
and the United States Air Force in 2017
Matt Boudreau founded Acton Academy
Placer schools that emphasized on
self-direction and cultivating confident
independent young people with a strong
sense of character and personal
responsibility he is changing the game
in education today and has since helped
to open multiple campuses around the
world as a husband and father his life
and family drives him to be the best
example he can be for his children who
are watching him I cannot wait for you
to hear our conversation I could have
gone on for hours with this guy and I'm
so glad I was able to get him on the
podcast welcome to the Ellen Fisher
podcast welcome into the podcast I'm at
I am so excited for this conversation
and thank you for being here I am
honored it's been a been a long time
coming so it's gonna be fun yeah there's
so much I want to talk about and I just
want to jump right in and ask you what
do you believe is the purpose of
Education
isn't that a great question
yeah what should education be for you
know and I talk about that a lot because
people don't ask that question you're
not asked that question when you go to
become a teacher you're not asked that
question as a parent you're not asked
that question as a student that's it so
my personal question and or my personal
answer that and I believe it is a very
personal question
right when you ask somebody what should
education be for what you're asking is
what should education be for for you
for your goals for who you are designed
to be and what you want to accomplish
all right so education for me is really
it comes down to sovereignty if you're
taking a look at the roots of of the
words education and you know EduCare
means to to draw out you want to draw
out the unique
the abilities of that specific
individual but there's also you know you
want to scaffold
the the awareness the self-confidence
the
um you know the understanding how to
build the life that person wants to so
ultimately it comes back to sovereignty
and freedom to be who you want to be to
do the things you want to do
and how do you think that differs from
our modern education system today
and it's gracious it's the antithesis
you know and it I always I always like
to preface these kind of conversations
with the understanding that I I am on
the side of good human beings who are
teachers and administrators in our
modern system
and when I say modern system I don't
just mean Public Schools I also mean
private schools because private schools
are modeled very much after the the
public school system if you're a good
human in those systems I am on your side
I love you I thank you I appreciate you
I want nothing but the best for you I
think you need to be there because those
systems aren't going away and there are
some young people the reality is you're
going to be the best human beings
they're going to meet because they go
home and the humans that are raising
them are not quite as as uh intentional
not quite as loving right so I want
those people there
my beef is always with the system itself
so you asked how is that different well
the difference is
the system that we utilize is a system
of schooling schooling and education
aren't the same if education is for
sovereignty and drawing out that unique
ability and being able to scaffold a
life
that you want to live well it's the
antithesis because schooling says
everybody do the same thing at the same
time in this very narrow
uh scheme of Academia that doesn't
really necessarily transfer over to
anything else in life it's not a system
that is easily transferable and I always
tell people it's like you know you go
for 12 years every day to learn how to
play checkers and then all of a sudden
you graduate and everybody's like okay
cool here's your basketball go shoot a
three-pointer and you're like wait I've
been playing checkers for 12 years right
it's well like yeah but they're both
games
okay but they're very different games
that require very different skill sets
and they have very different rules so
being good at school and and we know
this
being good at school does not
necessarily mean you're good at life
some people are good at school and then
they go out and they crush it but I
would say it's in spite of not because
of because you and I both know people
that didn't do well in school but
they're phenomenally successful they're
wildly happy they're very intentional
about their life we also know people who
got the Straight A's and are miserable
and have you know the success hasn't
transferred over right so that's my
problem with it is it's actually the
antithesis of what education should be
first of all I'm so glad that you
brought up teachers and affirming the
good teachers the good people that are
in our education system because I think
a lot of times people hear criticism of
the education system and assume it that
means that there's criticism of just all
the teachers lumping everyone together
when really that's not what you're
talking about
so yeah so I'm so glad you brought that
up at the beginning of this conversation
and then secondly when you're talking
about our education system and the
difference between what you think
education should be versus what our
modern system is
um a lot of times it feels like
education is meant to be for how to get
a job not how to be successful in life
and when you say success in life some
people think well that means when you
get a good job that's success in life
but success in life is
um could mean a lot of different things
and it's right not just to that so it's
a personal question right success for me
looks very different than success for
you because we're different people
there's some things that cross over for
sure and if you ask parents and I've had
the opportunity and again I've been a
public school teacher I've been a public
school administrator I've been a private
school teacher a private school
administrator I worked at Stanford I've
worked with universities all over the
world I know the game inside now and if
you talk to parents and you say hey what
are you you want for your young Heroes
when they get older
there is a somewhat of a baseline answer
right but the Baseline answer is I want
them to be happy I want them to be
healthy I want to be productive I want
them to have good relationships you know
I want them to be somewhat Sovereign I
want them to spend every day excited I
want those are the Baseline answers
nobody says I want them to be wildly
proficient at Algebra 2 when they're you
know that's never the answer right so
those are the baselines
so when you understand that that's the
Baseline you go crap well how do you
make sure that you have that for every
person it's a really tough thing to say
well there's a standardized process
when life is anything but standard your
you know our backgrounds are anything
but standard right it's almost
impossible to really make that to make
that happen
yeah because school is kind of set up
like our modern system is set up to
kind of for one type of learner as well
and I look at that the way my sister my
sister and I grew up because like you
said some people didn't do well in
school but are successful in life I
would consider myself one of those
people I wasn't horrible at school but I
wasn't great at it I hated test taking I
had to study so hard for it and then
just as soon as I finished the test it
was in one year out the other didn't
absorb any of it yeah right well and
you're talking about earlier getting a
job right and like that's the ultimate
like that's the end-all be-all that's
the goal so my career in public speaking
and when I say career in public speaking
there's a lot of people who uh you know
they say speaker uh or because they've
done some Keynotes and that's fantastic
I actually for many many years was doing
60 to 70 Keynotes a year for the largest
corporations in the country so I
actually had a career and this was while
I was building these schools so the
reason I was working with these
organizations so they were asking me to
come in because they were saying they
were hiring all of these Harvard and
Stanford and MIT and these graduates
there really really really really smart
really smart they're really good at
school
and they're going oh but we kind of want
to fire all of them because they're not
really good at work they're not really
good at resilience they're not really
good at right so even the grades to job
the employers are going okay this isn't
working
either so they're getting the job but
again it's not transferring over and so
you've got that experience it's the same
thing some people did really really well
at school I I did really well at school
I'm not that smart
I got the game I understood the game I
understood the pattern very early so I
got my Straight A's and then I got done
at school and went crap I don't know who
I am
I don't know what I'm good at actually I
I really don't somebody please give me a
job right and it there's so many people
that fall in that Spectrum you know and
none of that is what you would call
efficient or effective by any stretch
yeah and growing up my like I was saying
my sister is actually was actually
really good at school and yeah and
seeing us comparing it was like why is
it such a struggle for me I mean I'm I'm
saying it a little bit bigger than it
was I was not a like a really bad
student it was just that I had to work a
lot harder for it I was like a b and
sometimes a student and my sister could
just get A's without even studying it
was just came really naturally to her
and so growing up there's also that
comparison factor with kids like why is
it that you know my sister's having an
easier time and I'm not so I think all
of that comes into play in his really
relevant discussion that so many people
are forgetting to discuss when it comes
to our education
so true and again there's the natural
component right because you're a wildly
intelligent human being
I don't know about
that you know but that's the best thing
is I do know about that because and I
agree with you know we talked offline
before we started we were talking about
John Taylor Gotto and one of the things
that John said was that he had come to
realize that that genius was as common
as dirt hmm
and I believe that
wholeheartedly I believe that and genius
has a weird we have this weird
connotation in society where we think
that this is okay if you could label
somebody a genius well that means
they're Ultra academic and they know
everything all the time well nobody
knows everything all the time nobody
knows one percent of one percent of one
percent of all the things there are to
know in the world right but there's a
capability that is there there is a
potential that is there and it's a
unique capability and potential that can
really go forward and make big waves can
really go forward and change the world
you just have to find out what that
unique genius is for each person
and so again we're talking about this
very very very narrow game of school
that some people are inherently going to
be good at just like
some people are going to naturally be
better football players than others
but just because you know um I'm here my
brother's here we're same household he's
really good at football I'm not and then
we go uh I guess that means he's going
to be successful at life what it's not
the same game yeah it's not the same
quick little break for our sponsor bite
the best toothpaste on the market that
once you try it you'll never want to go
back to regular tube toothpaste well
most commercial toothpastes are filled
with harsh chemicals and artificial
preservatives and flavors stuff you
don't want to be putting in your mouth
let alone eating bite makes dry
toothpaste tablets made with clean
ingredients that are sulfate palm oil
and glycerin free and on top of that the
jars are so pretty it comes in these
beautiful refillable glass jars and they
send refills and compostable pouches so
they're better for our bodies and our
Earth no more plastic toothpaste tubes
bite toothpaste bits are so convenient
you just pop a bit in your mouth chew it
up and start brushing it will turn into
paste just like you're used to but with
no plastic tube or messy paste which
makes it extra convenient for kids who
think popping a bite in their mouth is
so fun and makes toothbrushing a
pleasant experience it honestly felt a
little weird at first but my whole
family is now obsessed it's so effective
and makes my teeth feel extremely clean
it's literally the best toothpaste I've
ever used bike makes plastic free
alternatives for everything on your
bathroom sink from toothpaste mouthwash
toothbrushes and deodorant so you can
cut out the harsh chemicals and plastic
waste without compromise and bite is
offering our listeners 20 off your first
order go to trybite.com Ellen or use the
code Ellen at checkout to claim this
deal that's
t-r-y-b-i-t-e.com slash Ellen
so what would be in your mind
how you would change our modern
education system let's say you had that
ability to do that what would you make
it what would you do to make it
different
well and I love that question and some
people will agree with a lot of what I
say and there's people obviously that
will probably disagree with certain
components and I think that's great I
think these are the kind of
conversations you need to have and we
need to understand that civil discourses
uh wildly valuable if we're ever going
to actually make progress now uh the one
cave you got before I answer this too is
understanding that uh government School
government schooling is not going to go
anywhere it's not going to change
um you know I've had so many people say
okay well how do we change this we won't
there's too much money power politics to
keep things the way that it is it's too
big of a clunky machine there's not
going to be any real change there but
what there is a there are a lot of
entrepreneurs mompreneurs dadpreneurs
who are stepping outside and going okay
then let's build something different
So my answer to how is really around the
how it's actually being done right now
building something different including
the schools that I built you know I had
all that experience in the public and
private sector
but I had my own young Heroes who were
growing up and my oldest I'm looking at
her going I can't send you to these
places I just can't and it's not a
Sheltering thing it's a I know this
isn't real education thing so I had to
build something different and I've now
partnered with entrepreneurs around the
world to do this very thing so
um it's a multi-faceted approach one
thing that we've done that's been wildly
successful is I mentioned civil
discourse we utilize the Socratic method
and the reason we do so is because we
want to stoke the Flames of curiosity
we want to make sure that Curiosity does
not die in a Traditional School System
curiosity is snuffed out on average by
about the age of eight kids come in
super fired up they're ready to go
they're super creative and that just
gets crushed out of the habit of
schooling
by the time the rate they're like all
right well I'm just playing this game
and and I'm either going to play it well
or I'm not or you know whatever that
looks like right so the Socratic method
we want people to understand we want
young Heroes to understand how to think
not what to think
how to think
how to articulate what it is they
believe and why they believe it to
provide evidence like what does a good
conversation look like what are the
rules of engagement on a good
conversation how do I listen to somebody
else's point of view and go okay I'd
love to hear your evidence and why you
think that and then they can have that
that you know they can share that back
and forth and at the end of it they can
go okay we agree on this we disagree on
this and hey by the way we can still be
friends
right like that's such an important
component of success no matter what
because at the end of the day Ellen you
and your husband don't agree on a
hundred percent of the things 100 of the
time
you're probably the closest person to
you right so what you just pack it up
and call like that's ridiculous you know
you come together on the things and you
and I would be the same way we could
find a lot we agree on we'll find a lot
we disagree on that doesn't take away
from the fact that I think you're a
really cool person and I like to be your
friend like that totally so so that
civil discourse and the Socratic method
uh is wildly important uh as a
foundational pillar another foundational
pillar is uh learning to set
one's own goals so we don't you know on
our campuses we don't issue Academia
altogether we just go okay we don't put
it on a pedestal
we want you to have different ways to
tackle certain Concepts not just the
Rope memorization and regurgitation how
does this apply to the real world
can we give you like a little mini
project that exemplifies this more than
just I'm gonna you know uh repeat repeat
after you kind of thing
but I learned to set my own goals around
that I learned to go okay by the end of
the week I want to accomplish this so I
become more Purpose Driven because I'm
starting to and I get some awareness too
of what I'm actually capable of
accomplishing in a short amount of time
so individualized goals matter
collaborative goals matter around
experiences so we put together big
experiences big exposure experiences and
let people collaborate to try to figure
out how to solve real problems together
and the exposure piece is again to let
people have a true sense of
self-awareness because they've actually
tried a number of different things
you know the analogy that I use for this
is
if you've only ever grown up eating five
different foods right and we have like
five different subjects in school as if
Life Works in subjects which it doesn't
but we have these five different
subjects right so yeah if you only had
five different foods and I said to you
Ellen what's your favorite food you're
like
um it's this one right or or maybe if
you're crazy or like oh I like to
combine these two
okay but if you've grown up eating a
buffet and you've been exposed to all
different foods from all different then
you are actually making a choice it's an
informed Choice and then you can start
to really get creative because you're
like oh if I take a little of this and a
little of this right and so it's the
same thing we want to expose them to all
kinds of different concepts we want to
expose them to all kinds of different
problems all kinds of different theories
all kinds and we do that in a
collaborative nature uh then we give
them massive amounts of responsibility
that's another thing and it's to me the
most damaging part of a conveyor belt
school system
is that we are teaching the young people
they are not to be trusted
um can you elaborate on that like
explain it a little bit more you bet you
are only allowed to uh really speak to
for the majority of the day people live
your own data manufacturer right like if
I'm six I'm only around other
six-year-olds so true right if I'm 12 I
hang out with 12 year olds I
automatically get to look down on the
youngers I automatically have to Revere
the odors
but then I'm going to stand in my
straight line I'm going to raise my hand
and ask permission for anything and
everything for years on end including
I'm going to ask another human being
even though I'm 18. if I can go to the
bathroom that human being might go no
and I go okay all right I'm learning to
be blindly obedient to anybody who
claims to be an authority I am this is
your assignment this is what you're
gonna do you're if you obey well I'll
give you an a if you go outside the box
on this you're not going to get the the
arbitrary letter grade that I'm going to
give you okay sounds good I'm working on
it ding Bell Rings move on to the next
part of the conveyor belt whether you're
enjoying what you're doing or not it
doesn't matter right it's this
Industrial Revolution model based on
authoritarianism
that builds that mindset into the young
Heroes
you leave there going I don't know
anything about me but I know how to obey
I know how to follow directions tell me
what to somebody tell me what to do next
and we wonder why when the government or
whoever claims to be Authority goes look
this is what you're going to do and this
is when you're going to do it people go
yep you got it sure whatever you say
right that's a big problem so we want
young Heroes to have massive amounts of
personal responsibility and that comes
on our campuses in many forms whether
it's teaching other young Heroes that
you're working with whether it is taking
on a job on campus it's cleaning up you
know the bathrooms at the end of the day
it's becoming the chef at school and
you're cooking the food for everybody
whatever that looks like you're taking
on massive responsibility and you're
also starting businesses you're taking
on internships you're taking on
apprenticeships you're doing hard things
early so that you see you're not fragile
and so you're building self-confidence
in that way too because self-confidence
doesn't come through affirmations
right affirmations have to be tied to
something otherwise you don't actually
even believe it so you've got to
actually do some hard things and stack
some victories there so that you can go
back on that so it's yeah it's a
multi-faceted approach to how you
scaffold that but we think all of those
things are are valuable pillars and
we've had a lot of really good success
with that that's amazing and I think
it's very important like you brought up
about just thinking we have to do
whatever we're told and losing our power
basically because you've said something
before about how this this statement
that we like to say that we want to
raise critical thinkers and we want to
help people our children to grow up
independent yet the actions that we're
we're doing to help them is actually the
opposite of that can you elaborate on
that a little more yeah that's exactly
right so it's the it's that walking
contradiction and it's the lack of
transferability right so I think
anything you're doing I think there's a
lot of power when things are uh
transferable
but there's a lot of power though what I
mean by transferable is and I use the
sports analogies
um I use Sports analogies a lot but
there's a concept in sports of of like
squaring up your hips and and having a
little bit of flexion in your knees and
kind of this ready position right in
that ready position you're ready to go
tackle the guy in football you're ready
to field the ground ball in baseball
you're ready to play defense in
basketball you're right it's a
transferable thing right
there's a lot of skills that should be
transfer barely any of the schools are
School skills are transferable
to to anything else because what you're
doing is You're Building these habits
and theoretically these habits
are supposed to transfer into okay now I
know how to be a self-sufficient human
being
well when your habits are
thinking no no you're telling me what to
do you're telling me to regurgitate the
information there's a very specific
thing I'm supposed to regurgitate back
there's a very specific time I'm
supposed to do this everybody does this
specific thing at this specific time
you are stripping the individuality away
from that person for 12 years straight
and then releasing him or her into the
world and saying
now go be an individual
yeah it is nothing like what it's
actually nothing yeah it's so true and I
think a lot of people have never even
asked the question what is the purpose
of Education because we're just told
this is what education is it's these
five subjects and no one has really
thought well what about all these other
things that are just as important if not
more important to have a happy life a
fulfilled life a life where you can
communicate well with other people like
you said going back to that civil
discourse thing that should be a core
important aspect of everyone's lives
growing up because so many people grow
up not knowing how to have conversations
with people that they disagree with and
getting tense about it feeling like I
can't speak to you yeah so much about
that and I think a lot of times people
might think well all those other things
about how to be a good human or
self-reliant human that's what what your
parents are supposed to do and then
education is just specific subjects what
would you have to say to that yeah
that's and that's great parents should
be leading by example a hundred percent
they should
but if you have to go somewhere else to
learn quote-unquote subjects when we
already know life doesn't work in
subjects what about statistics that show
uh you know maybe a home educated young
person who can go from when they're
ready developmentally speaking when they
go from uh just really starting to mess
with numbers until
wildly proficient in algebra and that
takes about a hundred total hours
total wow it doesn't take eight years it
doesn't take nine years so what are we
actually doing for that long
yeah and and again school was not
designed by if this was the 12-year plan
and all this kind of stuff was what was
going to make and the Academia Focus if
that was what was going to make strong
citizens well we've got like 92 percent
of our population has gone through this
system do we have a whole bunch of
educated happy well-rounded productive
human but we don't now I'm not saying
it's just school's fault but I'm you
know it's a multi-faceted thing but man
you would think we'd have so much more
success so
um you know especially with how much
time that we spend in school like
there's so much time because at home if
you're homeschooling you can get that
amount of work done at such a shorter
period of time and then you have the
rest of the day to fulfill all these
other important aspects of raising
healthy happy humans for sure and again
the academic focus of it is like yeah
does some Academia matter yeah a little
bit but it's very very little and to
think that it needs direct instruction
at a very specific time it's a cult
mentality we've been raised into and I
you know I asked people we did this kind
of like a little interview on the street
for this TV series that I shot that's
going to come out relatively soon and
and um people like okay yeah but I have
to say I'm not a teacher so I have to
send them somewhere so they learn this
I'm like oh that's great where did you
send them to learn how to walk
you're like well I didn't send them
anywhere right so they were just at home
with you how did you teach well I didn't
teach them so they just naturally what
you did was you encouraged the natural
trajectory that included failure
you encourage them to try something to
fail at it and to keep going they fell
when they tried to walk you went yay and
they went oh okay cool well guess what
learning how to read learning how to do
any kind of math that actually matters
and shows up in day-to-day life
including things like budgeting and you
know spending and all those kind
it's the same
thing it's the same process so if that's
the case what are we doing for so long
so again it goes back to what should
education be for and why does school
look the way it did and I love that
we've been talking about John Taylor
gato because teachers are not given his
materials when you go to get your
teaching credential
and it's because if you were given his
materials a lot of the teachers would
leave
can you explain for the people listening
who don't know who John Taylor Gotto is
who he is and what you like about him
yeah the man was a legend so he passed
away a couple of years ago
um he is a an absolute National Treasure
that almost nobody has ever heard of
um so John was a phenomenal teacher in
the public school system in fact he was
a New York state teacher of the year uh
multiple times so this man was in the
the game for over 30 years
uh his resignation letter went viral uh
because he started talking about how he
could no longer hurt children and not in
a physical sense he was talking about
the system of schooling so John is from
my money the foremost historian for why
School looks the way it does in terms of
the system why do we start at a very
early age why do we segregate based on
on age why do we segregate schools based
on class why do we have subjects why do
we have the processes
and he brings it back to this historical
narrative around this being a Prussian
military a lot of people think like oh
well this is how it must look because
we've always done it this way so I'm
sure there were some experts back here
at some point right that developed like
this is what human development needs
there were experts
but they were experts on how to break a
human system they were experts on how to
break a mentality so is this Prussian
system designed for Mass obedience in
the in the times of the Industrial
Revolution
and if you go read John's work he is far
more articulate than I am as far as that
goes and he breaks it down better than
anybody it was meant to make you a Slave
period
that's the problem it is meant to make
you a slave and there's this old saying
it's uh and I think I even sent you this
in the voice message last night but it's
like a bird's born in a cage think
flying is an illness
we're born at this point into the cult
mentality of schooling
we forget that for all of humanity we
learned by being at home together
pursuing the purpose of whatever the
purpose was for our family and we just
learned by doing that's how we've always
learned throughout Humanity the last 150
years or so has been this social
experiment of schooling
and the problem is well there's nobody
older than 150 right now that can tell
us like nah man this is the way it used
to be right so you're reward into this
cage and so what happens for a lot of
parents too is they even if they see
this from an intellectual standpoint and
they try to leave they fly out of the
cage
there's still this emotional tie to what
everybody else is doing and what they've
already known and they're like oh oh it
is just like if somebody was to leave a
cult and they're like oh but I think I'm
still still supposed to do the sacrifice
over here right still thinking right to
try to bring the cult back because they
can't quite emotionally let go of it
that's where we are with school in this
country it's the biggest cult we have
well it's something that like humans
tend to do in a lot of different ways
that if a majority of people are doing
something they like well I guess I gotta
do it there's so many
um visual experiments that they've done
where you're sitting in an office and
everyone else is doing this very bizarre
thing like standing up every time they
hear a bell and then they sit down but
they have no idea why everyone's doing
it and then they just start doing it
yeah that's right so that's that's the
important factor it's critical thinking
that's right it's like the and it's in
it yeah I mean critical thinking enough
to actually make you know critical
thinking is one part of that but then
there's also the self-confidence and
self awareness to avoid social
Conformity when it doesn't make any
sense yeah right that's a whole extra
level of Courage that you also have to
develop and scaffold in right you say
yeah I've seen those kind of experiments
the um
you know you've got the the whole and
it's not even just humans you got the
whole like crabs in a bucket you know
they're in there and they won't let the
other crab get out they'll pull the crab
back in because it's like you're gonna
Escape nope not you we're gonna pull you
back in right
um you know monkeys doing the same thing
when they're getting sprayed going to
get bananas and they're they're not like
it's a it's a weird thing that's baked
into us that we have to really think our
way out of totally and can you expand a
little bit more about why our modern
education system became what it is today
like the history of why did it why was
it created this way this model
yeah so I you know I always defer to
John's work on this because he will
explain it better so I'm going to give
you kind of the rudimentary
you know sort of explanation in the real
thirty thousand foot nuts and bolts but
go go read what he has to say about it
but
um the reality was we're on the
precipice of the Industrial Revolution
and there was a lot of uh there was a
there's a multifaceted thing but there
was a lot of money to be made in the
industrial revolution if we could get a
lot of people to automate the system
through you know getting all these
Factory workers they need to be smart
enough to obey and follow instructions
but not necessarily uh think for
themselves they needed to be made uh
comfortable and shown that hey if you
just come conform life is going to be
okay and we are going to take care of
you and so there were a lot of people
that stood to make a lot of money around
that the Rockefellers being one John
Rockefeller put in what
nowadays would be the equivalent of
about one and a half billion dollars
into the system and he said his words
not mine people get mad at me when I say
these things his words we want a nation
of workers not thinkers
they just wanted obedience
and so there was a giant push to make it
so that the you know there was just Mass
obedience but it also started this whole
chain
uh this whole chain of of issues where
we wanted more more and more obedient
people let's start splitting up the the
the natural family
um there was this entire element of how
do we control a population well if you
make it mandatory you require the young
people of the nation
to go into your religion your training
system for multiple hours a day for
years on end
not only will they not break out of that
religion when they get older
they will turn around have kids of their
own and feel compelled to put them right
back into that religion and that's why
no matter what I said at the beginning
Alan about the true my True Heart of I
care about good teachers and
administrators
some of them will still listen to this
and they'll still be mad at me they
won't go research the they won't go
research anything they'll say oh Matt's
against us they won't actually hear what
I'm saying but there are still also yes
that's true and then there are also some
teachers who really feel you and are
like I totally agree with you I feel
like there's so many issues and I'm just
doing my best to hold it together and
help the kids oh yes yes I talk to them
all day every day
all day I talk to teachers and
administrators from all over every
single day who are saying exactly that
and some of them are going
some of them are going I'm out I can't
do it anymore some of them are going oh
my gosh I still I just have to hold on
because you know retirement is eight
years away I talked to an administrator
from Pennsylvania this morning who's
like dude I'm nine years away from
retirement I just have to hold on all of
this is spot on you know I mean yes
that's that's real
and a lot of people a lot of teachers
have these amazing
um ideas on how to help kids grow but
they feel tied down to the system so
they're just doing the best that they
can so what yeah so what are some things
that you think our current modern system
is doing right is there anything that
they're doing well
you know the the best
things aren't even the things it's the
people you know we get a lot of there's
a lot of uh focus and understandably and
rightfully so on some of the woke agenda
kind of nonsense that gets thrown in
schools and I I agree like that's not
okay and there are some people that have
you know less than uh honorable
intentions for for being where they are
doing what they do yes those people
exist
the majority and again I was in that
system I have a lot of friends still in
that system there are a lot of really
good humans who are leading by example
nothing to do with the subjects they're
teaching they care and they show love
and they lead by example because they're
having civil discourse because they're
excited because they're coming with a
smile they're coming right that's the
biggest and best thing uh that that we
do
um you know and then some schools
depending on where you are you know I
mean they do provide uh
they do provide various Outlets the
sports programs are are great and sports
are something that I think is actually
wildly underrated in terms of things
that are helping our young Heroes so
you've got you know programs bits and
pieces here and there but to me it's
like
you know it's almost like okay yeah I'm
gonna eat my broccoli but I'm also gonna
you know drink this poison it doesn't
cancel it out so you still have the bad
habits that are being created there but
you do have some of those shining lights
but the majority of it is the people man
totally so why do you think people are
so afraid of customizing their own
education like why do people believe we
should put that in the hands of our
government is it just because of like
the Conformity factor or is there
anything else oh it's a conditioning
thing but it's the human nature
is such that freedom scares people
because freedom and responsibility are
two sides of the same coin
so if you really want to be free you
really want to be Sovereign there's a
massive level up in the amount of
responsibility that you have to take on
so
that level of responsibility is scary to
to humans in general that's the reality
it's easier it's why
um so many people are like ah be healthy
that's easier if you say there's a pill
I can take
I'd rather take the pill
right it's not think about exercise I
love what Gary vaynerchuk uh says and we
had him on the podcast a while back and
we were talking to him about it and says
look everybody knows how to work
everybody knows how to be in shape
everybody knows how to be healthy eat
eat good food and you work out like
everybody knows that
but it's the responsibility of actually
doing that day in and day out
where people walk
right so education all education is
self-education I actually can't teach
anybody anything they have to grasp it
they have to own it they have to decide
to incorporate that into their into
their life I can point to the Horizon I
can try to inspire uh you know I can try
to give you some information but
ultimately the end of the day Ellen's
got to receive it take it implement it
act upon it to make it a reality so
freedom is the same way you've got to
grasp that and all of the responsibility
that comes along with that that scares
the hell out of people
yeah and the leading by example thing is
so under like underappreciated people
aren't thinking about that near as much
as it should be because that's related
to even parenting
um the way that we raise our kids we can
teach our kids try to tell them what to
do but it's really what we're doing
that's going to affect them the most
Bingo yeah I always say like your kids
will do what you do before they do what
you say and they there's a massive if
they see a massive disconnect between
you say if you're like hey honey you can
be anything you want to be you can do
anything you want to do chase your
dreams and then simultaneously they're
hearing you say like oh what was me
money doesn't grow on trees I'm so upset
oh your father drives me nuts I hate my
job God it's Monday oh thank God it's
Friday can't wait for the win there's a
disconnect there and even if they don't
consciously get it subconsciously they
see it and it erodes trust for between
you and and your child but it also just
makes them not necessarily believe that
what you're saying is true so they start
to embrace that and like ah well life's
gonna kind of suck a little bit totally
and that's the bigger picture things
you're talking about and then it also
comes down to the individual things
we're telling them like don't yell when
your brother does this don't yell at
them but then you're yelling at them for
yelling
we don't hit yeah exactly yes it's that
yeah exactly it's called it's called
contradiction all right it's called it's
called being a hypocrite yeah uh we
can't we can't do it but it's really
hard for parents to like see even what
they're doing sometimes because you
think it's different I'm I'm parenting
my kids I I have to do this to teach
them but then your children start acting
in the same way that you're acting and
you see your father or your husband in
them and you see you in them and you
start it's like a huge mirror reflecting
onto you that's exactly what it is I
love the way you said that it is a huge
mirror that's exactly what it is and
people
um you know I'm always quick to make
sure I say this too because there's no
such thing as a perfect parent there is
not no and I've made you know just as
many mistakes as anybody else has on
this right there's no such thing as a
perfect parent
but I do believe we should always strive
to be the perfect parent and I think
that's okay to strive to really get it
right and to knock it out of the park
because we only have them for a short
amount of time and the way you parent
them is a gift that keeps on giving for
the rest of their life yeah right so you
want to try to do it as well as you
possibly can or you're going to screw
some stuff up of course you are but
let's do it the best you know to the
best of our ability but I'm very very
thankful because I always I get uh the
question very often how do you
discipline your kids when people meet my
kids because they meet them and they go
okay there's something different they're
very self-confident they're very
self-assured they're very at peace
they're very articulate they're very
friendly there's a joy
that comes off of them that is not what
you normally see for an 11 a nine and a
six year old there's a confidence that
comes off of them that you don't
normally see so they go how do you
discipline your kids
and I love it when I get that question
because I always tell them I don't
discipline my kids I have taught them
how to be a disciplined human being
and that's a very different thing and it
starts with me being a disciplined human
being it starts with my wife being a
disciplined human being it starts with
us being very very intentional about who
we are how we're going to pursue our
purpose how we're going to lead this
family and bringing our young Heroes
along with us
totally I love that and I want to read
something that you've said online before
which I think is just incredible and I
want people to hear it he said at the
end of the day your kids will have
watched you live or they will have
watched you exist your intentionality
around remaining inspired tackling
challenges with Grace remaining calm in
chaos and spreading positivity will be
noticed or it will be missed be noticed
I thought that was so good such a good
reminder for people
um and just in regards to the the whole
parenting education thing is all tied in
together and I love that you talk about
both yes ma'am it is the same thing it's
one and the same they're not separate
you know and thank you for that and even
with that you know when I'm
you know I say something like that and
and I don't always dive into the
comments because
you never know what was going on over
there I try to answer as much as I can
and help
um as much as I can but even with that
you know somebody's like okay yeah easy
for you to say but I get that a lot a
lot I actually get that a lot too I
think anything you do yeah I think
anyone
anybody who speaks boldly about anything
is going to get that because it's very
triggering for a lot of people and
instead of realizing that the trigger is
actually some something to notice that
is going on with inside them instead of
focusing it and putting it out on the
person who said the thing that made them
feel triggered Bingo man that's exactly
right yeah and they it's that that uh
that emotion gets drawn out so I don't
you know I never take it personally when
somebody comes back and it's just like
what I don't take it personally at all
and and if anything I just feel
empathetic I'm like man I wish you could
get up you know and I there's a part of
me too that wants to come back and go
okay cool well I grew up in an abusive
household I was also homeless for a
while I was also right
um in order to build all these schools
and to provide for the families that we
actually uh took a pay cut went from six
figures to 30 grand a year when we had
our you know our first kid and I went a
seven year stretch where I didn't take a
single day off but yeah easy for me to
say you know I there's a part of me that
still wants to come back with that I
know but yeah it does no good
um
it's understanding exactly what you just
said man that doesn't have to be a
personal thing that is their own thing
and I I genuinely want people to find
six of the people that come back and
they're like easy free I genuinely want
that person to find success or I've had
people come back later and go hey I got
pissed at you a couple years ago
but now this but now this but now this
thanks for at least being honest you
know yeah that's awesome I've definitely
gotten that to some emails before and
it's just it's really heartwarming
because you really just are trying to um
put out information that hopefully can
Inspire and maybe make people think a
little bit a little bit about something
they never thought about before and
there's kind of two kinds of people that
you often see either someone that can
take some information that they're not
doing it but they see that and you can
be inspired by it or you can see
information and then just internalize it
start criticizing yourself and and just
going Inward and feeling I could never
be that I could never do that but then
all that goes back to education and the
way that we raise our kids because we
want to raise them to be inspired to be
go-getters to not take things personally
to be critical thinkers to be able to
communicate well all those things to me
seem more important than like you said
algebra yes ma'am because then you can
you know you learn that resilience you
learn um you know what's a lifestyle is
an anti you're anti-fragile right at
that point yeah learn right how to learn
you learn how to learn once you
understand how to learn and you
understand that you have the ability to
learn anything you need to learn and
just as importantly you understand
that you're okay unlearning something
that's no longer relevant you learn to
let those things go when you have those
two things you have a superpower that's
going to last you the rest of your life
that's wildly important right and that's
not to say like you said like I said
about algebra it's not to say that
algebra is an important or we shouldn't
learn that or we shouldn't teach that to
our kids but what you're saying about
the ability to learn the ability to be
inspired and excited to learn that is
going to set them up for Success long
term to be able to learn whatever
excites them that's right that's exactly
it and whatever is relevant to to them
you know I tell people you know I have
people uh come back while I'm an
engineer and I use calculus every day
awesome you need it then good for you
like that's great then go get it I got
an A in calculus right now I couldn't
pass anything
past basic algebra if you gave me a
standardized test on anything I could
maybe pass an algebra test yeah and
that's about it but I know I could go
back and teach myself how to do all that
stuff if I needed to for some reason
right it's just not germane to my
specific goals and purposes yeah again
it's personal and that's why with
homeschooling I think a beauty of it is
that you get to tackle all those
subjects to get them the wide range of
things that they could figure out what
they're most excited about as they get
older and what they're good at but then
you also have more time to be able to do
all these other things that you're
mentioning before and what makes an
excellent education that's right and you
get to audit your own you get to audit
your own kids too because it's not you
know I have three I have three young
Heroes all three of them
have the same dad but they also have a
different dad right they have a
different Dad too because all three of
them need something different from me
they're all very different humans so
they need me to show up in different
ways and support them in different ways
because they're three different people
so you know we get to do that as a
parent uh and and have that level of
intentionality and it's it's pretty
awesome you know and we've got
um you know I have a group of families
from around the world that I lead
through through home education and so
you know I'll provide resources every
month but more importantly than just the
resources we jump on you know we have a
daily interaction through a platform we
jump on uh q a calls every single week
so that we can just talk through how's
everybody doing you know and what's
going on
uh in this last week you know one of the
um
moms who came on and and she just they
just joined the just joined this group
they've been uh in public schools for a
number of years she goes just in these
last two weeks I realized I don't I
don't actually know my kids
I knew the you know I got a couple hours
a day and I knew the version of them
that was post school and I knew the
version of them that showed up on the
weekends but they were on the weekends
getting ready to go back to school
I didn't actually know them
and that was powerful I wanted to know I
wanna know I know my kids inside and out
mm-hmm I know what they're think I could
look at them and I know what they're
thinking
yeah because I'm paying attention to
them so hard yep you know and that's the
level of intentionality that I
personally want as a father okay so two
questions stemming from that going back
to that reel that I shared when I was
having a chat with my sister and I
shared a quote that you had said
triggered a lot of people people were
really upset by it I know that you and I
had talked a little bit about that
um for those listing that don't know
what I'm talking about I shared a quote
that you said about how people feel like
they don't they're not qualified to
educate their own children so they send
them back to that same system
to educate their children
unqualified yes exactly and you
mentioned this earlier in the
conversation so what is your response to
someone who would say well it's
different because there's a difference
between learning something and learning
how to teach something
and so basically the criticism was
teachers are different but I mean I want
you to share your thoughts but I also
want to share one thing to me my initial
thought is well if that was the the only
prerequis requisite for being a good
teacher then that means anybody who went
to school to become a teacher would be a
good teacher but that's not the truth
because not everyone who becomes a
teacher are good teachers that doesn't
mean none of them are but not all of
them so it's more than that but I would
love to hear what you would have to say
exactly right I mean I've had teachers
again I've run schools I've built
schools I've had teachers that work for
me that had phds in education and they
couldn't teach their way out of a paper
bag
because they didn't actually care about
young people they didn't act you know
that it was uh teaching is more of a DNA
thing educating truly educating it's
more of a DNA thing than it is even a
skill set because you have to love the
individual you have to love people in
general and then you have to be showing
and walking alongside somebody through a
process not barking in order at them
that's a very different thing and so you
know and yeah you're right people got
very upset and triggered by that but a
lot of the comments were well he's not a
teacher he doesn't they didn't know that
they just didn't know it's my whole
career yeah I'm actually you know yeah I
was a uh you know I feel like I'm a good
uh teacher coach Mentor but it's it has
nothing to do with a specific skill set
I'm willing to go hey Ellen let's you
and I walk along this journey together
and figure that out right that's what
good education actually looks like is
that it's the willingness to go side by
side with you and go explore together
not for me to give all of my answers to
you and bark a bunch of information by
the way Google can do that yeah we have
so much information at our fingertips
now that we didn't have before we have
so many types of ways to uh have
curriculums if we want to have
curriculums within our education to help
that's right teach us how to teach our
children and all of it is together but I
also think when I look back at my own
education growing up it wasn't the
teachers that necessarily knew how to
quote unquote teach me something that
made a good teacher it was the passion
it was that the teacher was passionate
and excited to teach and grow with us
that that is what made a good teacher
that's what makes a good teacher and if
you and again all education comes back
to self-education so if you can you can
have the most excited I can have the
most excited person in the world who
loves the cello more than anything and
is so passionate and and is like Matt I
am going to teach you how to play the
cello I'm so excited about this look and
they're passionate and they're funny and
they're engaging and they're awesome
humans I could have that person and I
will appreciate their passion I will
love to watch them in their element
I
am so like there's no part of me that
wants to learn to play an instrument
there's just is not I just I've got zero
desire I will fight it tooth and nail
and their passion is not going to
convince me to do it so there's that
other element too right of like
all education is self-education the
receiver has to be excited as well so
with that being the case then really it
goes back to that DNA part the good
educator is the one who
looks at who the individual is too and
goes okay how can I Stoke their
curiosity how can I maintain that how
can I audit them to the point where I
know what they're thinking and I can ask
them the question that's going to make
them go oh my gosh and light up and get
inspired yeah right so always and
forever
parents are the number one educator in
their kids lives and there's not even
close to a second place if the parents
doing it right cool so I'd love for you
to expand a little bit more for people
who feel concerned or worried that they
won't be able to be good Educators and
how they can help educate and walk
alongside them their children if they
choose to homeschool like what specific
ways but before you answer that question
a little tangent something you said
about music uh it reminds me of growing
up how my mom put me in piano class I
did it for a short while but then I
didn't feel like going so my mom said
okay she's not interested you don't have
to keep going but as an adult I kind of
look back at that and almost wish that
my mom nudged me to keep going in some
things not like I had to do everything
but she was very very much like that
like oh if your child's not interested
like okay you don't need to do it but
looking back I kind of wish that I
learned some of those skills of certain
things that would be harder or take
longer to learn as an adult that I wish
I would have learned younger so do you
feel like there's a balance at all with
like if your child expresses interest in
a certain thing like a muse certain uh
music aspect or sports or something else
what's your rule of thumb for that with
kids like as they're getting older like
oh Mom I don't want to do this anymore
dad I don't want to do this are you like
all right they're not interested or do
you kind of nudge them to keep going
yeah that's a really good question and I
think that's a really nuanced
um it's got to be a nuanced answer and I
don't think there's a blanket statement
here so
um commitment matters
I still think that matters and if
somebody is truly interested in their
showing interest and you know with my
son's like hey I want to go play t-ball
and
um I want to go try okay cool you're
going to play and you're gonna finish
the season like if you can't be probably
through the season and say well I'm not
interested anymore because sometimes
what happens is they're not interested
right that second
and they because they're just tired or
they want to go play they know you'll
give them another option that sounds
better at that point and so they're
pulling the trigger on you to allow you
to go oh okay well then you go ahead and
go do this right so a lot of times when
our young people are saying they're not
interested in Summits because we have
given them Alternatives
um that sound better in the moment too
right so are you aware of those kind of
things because one of the things that I
talk about for parents is look my young
I think young people need massive
amounts of responsibility
as there's always chores to be done and
things they can do and things they can
tackle and take on and I think they also
need to be uh
really protected from distractions that
aren't wildly beneficial so if you've
got a young person that's got a lot of
responsibility does not have a lot of
distractions you're gonna see what
almost seems like an inhuman level of
commitment to some of these other bigger
ideals where it's like oh yeah I want to
tackle that and you'll know if there's a
genuine interest or it's a feigned
interest
and you'll you'll know if they've got
other distractions that they're really
trying to manipulate you to get back to
again you will know all of this if you
pay attention to them so what would be
some examples of distractions besides
like video games or TV
so video games are huge distractions uh
TV is a huge distraction
um the if I'm honest those are probably
the two biggest distractions for for
most people right the the tablets the
electronics like currently those are the
biggest distractions for young people
um I also you know it's not necessarily
falls under distractions but when I talk
about this with parents I talk about
medications and all that kind of being a
distraction too because it distracts
them from who they really are too and
puts them in this weird state so if
that's a whole another conversation that
parents get very upset at me about but
yeah you know it's another thing but
those electronics are some of the
biggest some of the biggest distractions
uh so far so let's see before I have
that other question there's so many
things I want to talk about I know get
back to that get back to that but about
the um the video games that's a big one
especially for boys huge super big so
what are your thoughts on how you manage
something like that do you have like a
strict no video games in the house or do
you have like a healthy amount aspect
what are your thoughts on all that yeah
I am not a huge fan of video games
period And this is another thing that
gets people very very upset about well
you can build a you can you can have a a
great life as a video game designer you
could yes you can you bet yeah you bet
it's gonna be a rare exception to the
role it's going to be very rare yeah for
sure and if but you know what if you
want to give them something where
they're jumping on game star mechanic or
whatever it is where they want to learn
to build out a specific game yeah you
want to put a certain amount of time
around that and just have a time frame
cool man Go Get It Go Get It yeah like
let's see if that Designer if really
what they're after is the designer part
of it they want to create like great go
for it
99.9 percent of the time that's not the
case right now video games are works of
art especially now they are phenomenally
done they're they're wonderfully done
and they're meant to suck you in
what happens for our young men and again
I'm not just
the old guy with the white beard that's
anti video game like that's not it
I work with young people and I've worked
with thousands at this point
I can tell you especially for young men
there is a DNA component for being a
young man and hey by the way I was a
young man as well right so there's a DNA
component where you want to go on an
adventure
you want to go conquer something
you want to go save the princess you
want to go slay the dragon you want like
that's wired into us that we want to
express it it's why we want to go play
sports we want to get outside we want to
we want the adventure what happens for
too many young men as all of a sudden
the adventure is in this box
and we're checking off
all of that DNA component inside of us
but we're doing it in a virtual world
that doesn't actually transfer to
anything good so then when we're outside
in the real world it's just the noise is
turned down by comparison totally don't
want to go get after our Drive goes down
because man I can go get all my dopamine
over here I don't actually have to go
even talk to the pretty girl anymore and
and potentially get rejected I can just
you know I can just do this here swipe
this way or that way whatever way you're
supposed to swipe right like I can do
everything virtual everything gets
turned into that and so it really has
been killing the drive for a lot of our
young men so I'm just not a huge fan in
general yeah personally can people will
go my son
that's where he learns he socializes he
leads he great man go get I'm not
telling you how to parent that's fine
but
there is a difference between
socializing via headphones and actually
having to look somebody in the eye and
interact there is a difference between
leading leading somebody on a mission in
Call of Duty versus leading in a public
setting at a in a sports game where now
I'm shooting free throws to win the game
or lose the game and everybody else is
around me my failure is public or my
success is public there's a there's just
a different level of stakes it's not an
Apples to Apples comparison
um so you know I
I worry about it a little bit because
again based on experience I've had so
many young men who have told me this
firsthand yep
I 100 feel you and I am actually having
a conversation with Chris McKenna next
week I don't know if you know who he is
but he has
um protect young eyes I'm interviewing
him next week for the podcast on
um kids and social media
um and all that getting on screens too
early totally 100 on board with you I
feel like a lot of people listening and
watching right now might be in the same
position as maybe I am where you have
the same thoughts about what you're
saying but they also are around other
kids and friends who have video games
and you also don't want to be like no
you can't play video games ever you
don't ever get you know so you're like
what's the healthy balance and the way
that we have it in our family right now
is
um like working for like it's like a a
short reward at the end of the day after
you accomplish all your other things
well that's good right yeah it is it is
the freedom gets handled or
responsibility gets handled first and
then you get freedom and it's always
that order right so that's I you know I
always try to express to young people
that responsibility again responsibility
and freedom are linked the more freedom
you want well if that moved up
responsibilities got to move up as well
right because they are linked together
you've got the more freedom you want the
more responsibility you've got to take
and responsibility always comes first
and it's such a good thing to teach kids
that it's so good to teach them like to
get everything done check everything off
your list that you know you need to get
done for the day and then you can relax
and do you know the little thing that
you want to do and then you can do the
things you want to do yeah that's
exactly right that's exactly right and
then if you find yourself whether you're
a young person whether you're an older
person you're a full-grown adult you're
whatever you find yourself in a spot
where you're complaining about something
you wish you had or wish you could do or
wish you well that is your your you know
trigger to understand cool I'm gonna
have to level up on the responsibility
first and and maybe let the freedom you
know the freedom piece slide for a
little bit so that I can get to that
next level of whatever that looks like I
think that's a healthy way to go about
it yeah and not um over exposing like
picking very specific types of games
that are you know gentler on the mind
you know Kinder games and also short
periods of time rather than long periods
of time yeah that's kind of our rule of
thumb but I it's such a fascinating
topic because it's one of those things
where you don't want to be the one that
your kid goes up and goes my mom didn't
ever let me ever do this this or this in
the name of quote unquote protecting me
but you also want to have find healthy
balances yeah for sure and that you know
it's I I agree 100 and it's that it
comes down to the intentionality you
know and I I don't worry about my young
my my young Heroes really being like Oh
dad never let me whatever because
they're so
busy
kicking ass yeah that's not you know
what I mean like it's not even
necessarily it's not even necessarily a
draw
because they're so busy doing something
that they're not looking backwards at
whatever is over there and I'm guessing
does that have a lot to do with what
you're providing them and this goes back
to education for parents they're like
okay well how do I do this I don't feel
confident I was raised in the regular
system like what would you suggest for
them to set their kids up for that to
where they feel totally inspired and
excited to go after and learn throughout
the day all day that's yeah so is the
parent excited to go after and learn all
day every day yeah that's where it
starts I wake up every day I am Purpose
Driven I've got a mission I am wildly
curious I know I'm going to learn some
things I know I'm going to talk to some
amazing people I know I'm going to have
something that's kind of hard and I'm
gonna have to get through it like I know
all those things are there and I'm
excited and I'm taking my kids along
with me right so we are meeting as a
unit it's almost like this business sort
of structure where it's like cool man
what do you have today what do you have
today what do you have today we all have
our list our purpose like all right man
let's get after and like then let's
check in and see how everybody's doing I
mean we run it almost like a
um you know it's really this tight
military unit or business operation I
mean we are all like let's go
um and if there's any downtime too I
want them to come with me and take a
look okay here's what I'm doing right
now here's what's going on here's what
I'm looking at in terms of
um you know our budgeting or this
various company that we run over here
and and here's kind of the cash flow and
I'm looking at the p l they don't have
to understand
all of that people get mixed up and they
go well your kids don't understand you
know a full p l right now at six no I
didn't say they did yeah but they're
excited that I'm excited and then I'm
like this is where money comes from you
know yeah yeah yeah okay cool right and
so it's a concept that they're now being
made aware of what parents need to
remember is we are establishing
for our young Heroes what they consider
to be
normal
we're establishing that
so if being excited and Purpose Driven
and focusing on real world outcomes and
intentional about our relationships and
intentional about what we stay away from
but focus more on the few like if all
those things are the normal
that becomes the mentality for them that
becomes their Baseline
right and and you can individualize at
that point
right so I can't give a parent a blanket
State you know when I work uh with all
these parents that I bring through a
home education uh situation I send them
a menu of projects and challenges for a
month that have a given theme and the
whole thing is cool man if you guys want
to test these out do these together do
these experiments these projects these
things together but take a look at the
rest of your day what else do you guys
want to put in so for our family you
know we've got I'm doing specific things
in the morning my heroes are all there's
specific chores out on the farm that
they're taken care of then they come
back and they've got individual academic
goals that they're jumping into
individual books that they're excited
about in the afternoons
um you know we're taking a look at
projects together whether that's
projects they're working on projects I'm
working on for work like we're
collaborating around that just so we can
see what each other is doing and then
they each have their individual you know
ones goes to work with horses and go
ride horses the other one goes to
gymnastics another one goes to ninja
warrior class and we're all doing all of
this together we are living
what we feel like is an adventure
yeah and that's the Baseline for normal
that's awesome so it's all I'm
encouraging people to do love that and I
I think it's helpful to bring to this
conversation
um something that I've spoken to shafali
saberi about do you know who she is
she's a parenting author no ma'am okay
well she has this counter experience
about the obsession that sometimes
parents have with doing too much like
constantly getting your kids to go here
and go there and go there all in the
name of creating the perfect
quote-unquote kid and so her message is
very like let your children be normal
like let your children be average is the
word average she's like there's nothing
wrong with letting your children be
average and I find this beauty in what
you're saying and what she's saying at
the same time to be a good balance
because someone who might be listening
what you're saying is like great great
but then also if if there's also
neglecting the other aspect of downtime
averageness what are your thoughts on
that yeah and and you know I want that I
I I'm glad you brought that up because I
want to be able to articulate dude there
are times when they don't have something
scheduled especially in the afternoons
because they've gotten all of the the
responsibilities have been done right
and then I might have a day where i'm
doing
um I guess on four or five podcasts
right and I got it today I get to do a
few podcasts today gets it like this is
awesome this is great amazing this is
part of my mission and this is uh well
that's not anything they're necessarily
going to join me for so that in the
afternoon they don't
have anything to do
so the distractions are still not an
option this afternoon it's not like well
sit around just watch TV the whole
afternoon and play video games right
you got down time so you figure out who
you are and what you want to do with
that they might just go they might just
go outside and hang out and play they
might sit on the porch and read they
might decide to grab Legos they do yeah
like they just decide to be a kid and
they guess what it's okay for them to
get bored because boredom fuels
creativity right yeah like all of that
is is fine as well so what do you say to
a kid who's like I'm so bored dad I
don't have anything to do and I don't
want to do any of it what's your what's
your response to that they don't say
that anymore because
because the only if the times that
they've had that they have said that to
me my response has always been there's
no such thing as being bored there's
only being boring
I love that that was my response and so
now they won't even say it to me because
they know that's the response yeah I
love that so they know that we don't
care if they're bored it's okay if
they're bored are there other
responsibilities taken care of if there
are responsibilities are taken care of
then at that point it is up to them to
decide what they want to do love it
because guess what
that's how it works
forever yeah Alan gets bored Ellen's got
to figure out what to do with herself I
can't even remember the last the last
time I've been bored
the last time that I've had nothing to
do or nothing I wanted to do is very
like never that's a great thing and
there's too many adults that will go
I'm bored so I guess I'm gonna binge
watch eight hours of Netflix and then
they're also usually the ones that
complain about how they wish they had or
they wish they could or they wish they
did you know so I want I want them to
just grasp uh that's again that
sovereignty
early love that so so do you have a list
of resources for anyone who's new to
homeschooling and wants to figure out
how to navigate what you're saying to do
and what they what resources they could
provide their kids like what are your
favorite homeschooling resources yeah my
my favorite resources because again when
you're talking about resources it's like
okay well what should education be for
what do you want to do so there's a you
know Ranch down the street and that's a
homeschooling resource there's
gymnastics center over here that's a
homeschooling because you're just living
life and and being educated in the
process you can go
like everything is a resource everything
is a resource so my favorite when people
ask that is it's anything that's going
to get the parent out of the mindset of
bringing School home right because like
I gotta teach Academia dude my friend
Sal Khan has something called Khan
Academy that will literally teach you
every single academic subject you could
ever want for free the resources are
there right master class is there udemy
is there you can look up moocs moocs
most universities put a ton of of their
courses online for free interesting
you're not going to get credit
necessarily you're not going to get
school credit yeah but you can take the
course right you can go take a lot of
Harvard courses if you want
like the resources are abundant
so when people say what are your
favorite resources for home education
the real resources are what are what do
you need to learn and unlearn do you
need to unlearn the school mindset go
read John Taylor Gotto do you need to
get more towards a freedom mindset you
got kids that you want towards a freedom
mindset go read total twins Tuttle twins
are great you know yeah I love your kids
love Tuttle teams oh Connor's a dear
friend of mine man oh no way that's
awesome oh he's a great guy and he just
sent my kids a freaking rad video the
other night
um they loved it man he said
um such a good such a good dude
um that's awesome so you know I I don't
have any specific like resources that I
love because to me that's like a
well if people are starting to eat what
food should they eat yeah man that's a
wildly wildly individual conversation
totally there's there's a lot of
different things to choose from and it
depends on what your child is most
inspired by yes ma'am that's exactly it
and what's going to inspire you as the
parent
so what is your advice for those who
would like to home educate I like how
you say home education I'm so used to
saying homeschooling or unschooling but
I like education you've been using that
home education it sounds more accurate
to me because homeschooling isn't school
you're not trying to replicate or copy
what school is you're creating your own
education yeah so that's that's a much
better term but what's your advice for
those who would like to home educate but
feel they can't because of their life
situation maybe they're a single parent
or both parents are at work or
um they like you said uh they are
feeling educated up to homeschool but we
covered that one or thoughts on those
who live in a country where it's illegal
to homeschool because I actually have a
lot of people I get messages from that
from people a lot about that
me too so that in of itself is a much
harder nut to crack because I get those
as well
um I've got a running conversation with
quite a few families some who are quite
literally fleeing the country they are
in so that they can do this and is it
different in certain are there other
some countries that have better
education systems than America are there
are some countries that actually educate
more versus school right right so
Finland is one that comes top of Mind
finland's government schools are much
more like the schools that we have built
out here not we as in the government as
in myself and the entrepreneurs that
I've worked with right there's their
schools look much more like that and the
students don't even start until they're
seven and at that point it's not
academic bases more character based and
then they're done by 16 and they have no
homework and they have you know it's all
of these things they learn to
self-educate and take on responsible
ability so it's awesome you know so in
that case I think you're you're in a
great spot the families that are you
know in in these countries where it is
illegal
um
to me it's very similar to you know
maybe somebody who is out here who is a
single mom and really doesn't have
anybody else around like
to uh
because I know single moms that can make
it work too because they get uh somebody
to watch the young Heroes during the day
and then they focus on all the
educational opportunities when they are
together right like I know some moms
that make that work I also know that
it's not fully possible for everybody in
that situation and I don't blame them
for that so to me it's the same thing as
the person who they're in a system that
doesn't a lot or a country that doesn't
allow them to home educate
you're still home educating
when you're together with them you still
are home educating
you just have to be intentional about
talking to them about what they're going
to do during the game of school
right so one of my mentors a gentleman
named Seth Godin do you know who Seth is
by any chance okay so Seth is a
phenomenal uh speaker author uh
marketing genius he's written like 20
some odd bestsellers he's a phenomenal
guy
um
Seth said you know my daughters went to
school they went to Conventional school
I just made sure that they knew the game
they were playing while they were there
we were very intentional about what that
game was going to look like for them so
that they understood what they were
playing and why they were playing it
they didn't take certain things too
seriously they were very intentional
about relationships about leading about
looking for certain patterns and then we
worked on their education when they got
home
um love that right okay so for parents I
mean I I think it's that you know it's
going okay look we've got a little bit
of the deck stacked against us let's be
intentional so they know what they're
going into so that they're avoiding some
of the bad habits the mental habits that
we were talking about earlier and then
they're really going after who they are
and what they want to do you know when
when they get home
um so if you've got to do that find your
balance you know in in that regard
um
you know I think that's that's that's
about the best bet for so many parents
though I think really what it is is they
feel like there's a fear of doing they
could they could make it work we could
do it we could figure it out
but there's all those fears of oh we're
gonna mess up our kid
yep oh there's also the or sometimes
they just don't have a desire like
knives no
I've no it's unto me that that makes me
beg other questions that makes me sad
yeah
I don't I want to be around my kids all
the time yeah I want to be around them
all the time I mean I enjoy the heck out
of them man they're they're great human
beings to be around like so what's going
on there you know and for someone who is
like both parents work but they would
like to homeschool a lot of times
there's ways around that if you can
reassess your life situation feel like
is there a way to downgrade so we don't
have to earn as much money and we can
have one parent going to home or going
to school the other parent could be at
home or could we do part-time somewhere
so that we could switch off with other
families maybe there's a lot of
different ways to get creative that a
lot of people just don't consider do a
homeschool Co-op kind of deal where it's
like okay well our off days are you know
we're off Saturday and Sunday but
they're off you know Wednesday and
Thursday and these guys are off Monday
and Tuesday and they and yeah and you
can make those kind of things work
you're right but it's that kind of thing
too where you're having to prioritize
and downsize and shift
that's where it irks me when people go
oh easy for you to say
no I left a six-figure position and went
to thirty thousand dollars a year
with my wife no longer working uh-huh
and we still made it work so she could
be home with our oldest yeah so that we
and there was a big sacrifice and it was
really really hard and I would go back
and do it again ten times out of nine
yep ten times on a night I love that
have you and honestly all of this ties
into everything together like your
parenting you're educating not like the
example you're raising with your kids
and even finances right so if you're
inspired by this you're like oh we're
just stuck so much so much of what is
status quo is just being stuck in this
conveyor belt life it's not even just
conveyor belt school but conveyor about
life of like that's right you gotta earn
this amount by the super nice car and
you have to keep up with the Joneses and
then we don't have time to be with our
kids as much send them off here I gotta
go to work drive in the car to get home
to pay for the house that you know all
that stuff together that's right that if
you re-prioritize your life there's this
great documentary called playing with
fire I don't know if you've heard of it
it's a financial Independence retire
early and so it's all about how to be
able to
um spend less save more to retire early
like there's this Obsession or not
Obsession but there's just mindset that
we all have to retire at 65. but where
does that even come from we have to work
all day every day until we're 65 like
that's nuts to me so yeah that's crazy
to me on a number of accounts because so
number number one to think that I have
to work a job I don't like for that long
yeah to to pay for everything is crazy
and number two the concept of doing a
bunch of things you hate for 40 years
today theoretically enjoy your life but
to sit and do nothing at 65 too because
you don't know who you are or what like
that also sucks I will be working until
the day I die because I enjoy what I do
in my mission but I don't want to have
to for any kind of financial reasons at
all yeah I just want to be living my
life the way I want to live my life
exactly you want the freedom yes that's
the freedom the freedom the sovereignty
yeah that's what we're talking about I
do what I want to do with who I want to
do it and all the other needs are taken
care of like yeah that's what we should
be going after and that's not in a
braggadocious way that's just what
Freedom means
yes love that and that I'm sure you know
who Dave Ramsey is right I know Dave
yeah I know I'm going out to Ramses I'm
going out to their Studio relatively
soon right that's awesome I interviewed
uh his daughter Rachel for the podcast
earlier I would love to get him on the
podcast too I just love the topic of
finances and that's actually one of the
reasons why I started this podcast
because I want to talk about all the
things that I feel has like made our
life excellent you know and what what
can help other people make their life
just so excited about everything that
they do
um but I brought up Dave Ramsey because
it's like something he says is like live
like no one else so that later you can
live and give like no one else and so
it's it's the long-term thinking yeah
it's huge and again it's a different
game it's a game you don't learn how to
play you don't learn how to play the
finance game you don't learn how to play
you know you're taught okay well you got
to go to work you got to pay your tax
what if I told you you don't have to
actually even pay taxes right you just
have to know how that game works
yeah and then you choose to play that
interesting most people don't want to
know that there's other games outside
the conveyor belt thing they've been
told that their parents also did that
everybody in their neighborhood they
don't stop to take a look and go is
there another game to play here that's
interesting I don't know much about this
tax thing you're talking about I have to
do a whole other episode on that I'm
telling there's a million different
games to play you know and so it's
choose the games you want to play man
because there's a lot
so what about let's let's switch gears a
little bit on something
um many people have uh concerns about
home education because of socialization
it's compulsory School Quality Social
socialization or not what are your
thoughts on that that's such a great
yeah I love that question and when
people ask me that I always go yeah man
you are right socialization is a big
deal I would be really worried about the
socialization somebody is getting in
public school
I would be really worried about that
very much so because what does
socialization mean and well who who is
so you're always being socialized your
young kids are always being socialized
the question is who's doing the
socializing what are they being
socialized for right so again going back
to those mental habits so you're telling
me that you would rather have them have
all the adult uh figures in their life
teach them that you know anybody that
claims Authority gets it you would
rather have that be a social component
you would rather have the majority of
the people speaking into their life
if your child's six the majority of the
voices all day long or other
six-year-olds you don't know who that
six-year-old is and what kind of life
that person has and what kind of things
that person is seeing at home you want
them being some of the main voices not
you not you you want your other
six-year-olds strangers to to be the
main voices
um that are there you've got all of
these never mind the bullying things
even in some of your quote unquote good
schools you've got kids that are you
know uh twerking in the freaking quad at
lunch you got kids having sex and vaping
in the bathroom so you gotta get this is
the socialization that you want yeah
like as an adult
and parents go well yeah you got to
learn that you know there's some things
that aren't so cool sometimes you got so
okay cool so then as an adult if you
want to level up and get better
do you go well I better put myself in
prison for a few months to learn that
there's shitty people out there like
what no you expose them to Greatness you
expose them to your ideas your morals
your ethics and then you're intentional
about other social situations and that's
the so again what you make normal
becomes they're normal
so yeah do we home educate we do and
guess what we sold some uh goats not too
long ago there was a guy that was coming
to buy them for Land Management over
there we had a bunch of babies and so we
had a whole bunch of goats so this guy
comes to buy the goats and so I know
he's on the way so I'm going down the
hill to go bring these goats up to him
and when he gets here my nine-year-old
greets him says hi my name is Brielle
you know she shakes his hand my name is
Brielle nice to meet you thanks for
coming you must be you know you must be
Jed and he's like yep nah she's like
okay so I've got the invoice for you
right here so here's what I'm gonna need
you to do I'm gonna need you to sign
this and then I'll take a picture of it
that'll be our copy I'll give this to
you so you can keep this and then it's
going to be you know we can only do cash
it's going to be x amount of cash you
can give me the cash dad's down there
he's getting the goats right and so I
brought the goats up and he goes
where did she learn like what she's so
wildly cough I'm like yeah
she's this is normal for her talking to
adults dealing with the adult adults
they call the restaurants that we work
with to see if they need new orders like
they'll go do the deliveries they're
talk that's socialization
yep being able to interact with
different age I think that's one of the
biggest
yes one of the biggest factors of
socialism like healthy socialization in
kids is when they can get in a group
with different age people wide range of
different age from children and babies
to older cool kids or Just older kids in
general and to adults like being able to
interact with everybody in confidence
um and help like help out with babies
and all that that is like amazing
socialization I think a lot of people a
lot of people think that homeschool
homeschooling they imagine like living
off grid in this little cabin where you
don't see anybody else for months at a
time and they say where's your
socialization but that's really like not
the the rule that's generally not what's
happening that's generally not what's
happening no we're going out to the
store they're going out to restaurants
they're going to activities they're
going to they're talking to other humans
all the time but they're doing it in a
real world environment they're doing in
a real aspect they're very comfortable
talking to older talking to younger like
there's nothing weird people go oh I
knew a homeschool kid once you know I
was younger and they were very very
weird did you know any weird kids at
your public school too because you did
right totally if school was the answer
to weirdness we wouldn't have had any
weird kids and you know it's it's yeah I
think because my mom had this fat this
idea of why it is that there's a stigma
that homeschooled kids are weird and I I
think that that stigma is pretty much
dispensed at this point because
homeschooling has exploded so much but
back when I was growing up very few
people chose to homeschool and my mom
said I don't think it's the homeschool
kids that weird I think it's just that
the people who chose to homeschool were
weird it was like the weird families at
the time chose to homeschool and so they
were just different but it's just not
like that anymore that's it I always I
always had Parents sort of you know oh
gosh if I homeschool my kid aren't they
going to be weird and I go if you're
weird yeah if you're weird totally
because I think about when my son Elvis
he's my oldest he's 11 now but when he
was like two years old we would go into
the grocery store and all of the
employees knew his name everyone knew
his name and he knew all of their names
and they would all talk to him say hi to
him say goodbye to come give him hugs
like he just knew everybody at such a
young age and if your kid is at school
obviously two is younger than in America
where people are generally sending their
kids to school but there is daycare and
everything where they're only around one
age a lot of times they can get into the
real world and they don't know how to
talk to anybody that isn't their mom or
dad or a two-year-old or whoever
whatever age that they're in bingo I
know a lot of you know young people that
are wildly well schooled but again
that's part of why I'm getting brought
into these organizations these kids are
very well schooled but they're not very
socialized they don't understand how to
talk to customers they don't understand
how to work with clients you know none
of that is is necessarily prevalent for
them yeah because yeah it's one of the
biggest myths and it's one of those
things where we just kind of repeat it
because it's been a call again it's the
cult mentality you just repeat it you
just say it what about socialization you
just say it because you're taught to be
afraid yeah that that's like a thing
without actually giving it some thought
what does socialization means it means
you understand how to interact with the
world around you and that normally you
are willing to conform to the
environment well if that's part of the
definition and I'm looking at the way
the majority of the world operates I
don't necessarily want to conform to the
rest of the world that doesn't know who
they are and they're kind of sad and
they don't necessarily I don't want to
conform to that sure as hell don't want
my kids to conform to that right so true
crazy too yes I love that
um so how difficult is it to educate
children of different ages together if
you're trying to I know that though like
your examples of just like doing life
together and how empowering that is
because so much of what we talk about
the modern system is very disempowering
for kids like you said you sit you
listen to the teacher you can only go to
the bathroom if they let you go to the
bathroom and there's only the specific
thing you're going to learn not this
other thing you're interested in that's
not part of the thing like all that
stuff is disempowering for kids and I
totally felt that growing up
um but when it comes to home education
and educating children of different ages
does it make sense sometimes why like
how the modern system became the way it
is because do you find it difficult at
all to do curriculum style things with
different ages at the same time
it's just you're just living life with
people of different ages how old may I
ask how old you are I am 35. dude I'm so
much I'm 43. why are you talking to each
other I know shouldn't we not right why
are we ridiculous I know that's right
and and gosh shouldn't I find out if at
35 you're making the same amount of
money as I did at 35 so we could know
who was ahead and who was behind and
totally it's silly like that none of
that plays out in real life
um and it actually ends up being wildly
beneficial because you know my young
heroes are very self-directed they're
all going after their individual things
but they can all help each other as well
so my six-year-old is like I don't
understand this well awesome his
nine-year-old sister or his 11 year old
sister come over and go oh here it is
totally how to help you and they come in
and they actually help to teach him or
to help walk him through something that
he doesn't understand so I love that
wildly beneficial and we and part of
that you know the fear around that
concept comes from this school uh
mentality that there are certain things
or certain boxes that need to be checked
at a certain time of life and you know a
certain developmental stage and that's
just not correct
um I think even a lot of homeschoolers
have that like they might be really
confident in homeschooling but there's
still this like oh but I gotta do this
specific thing or else they're not gonna
yeah or else they're not gonna be at the
same level as their peers or whatever
right which is again just a silly thing
right otherwise it does that map out in
the real world does that map out for
adults if another 43 year old is
listening to this and he or she does not
make as much money as I do are they
behind
or RMI ahead how do we measure who's
happier how do we measure like it's just
it's a silly thing that doesn't exist in
the real world but we put this weird uh
box around it in school you know and I I
use the example A lot of times when I
speak uh on education in public I'll
I'll walk out and and um you know start
having conversations and
I'll ask the audience did anybody look
at me when I walked out on the stage and
think ooh okay that guy was a late
Walker
oh no no I didn't learn to walk until I
was 18 months old so was I behind and
did that hinder me long term well I end
up being a really good athlete I end up
being a good martial artist I end up
being a five nine white guy that could
dunk a basketball like I was a pretty
good athlete but I didn't start walking
until I was 18 months old well I know a
lot of very successful people
I know somebody who won a a very
prominent award for writing a phenomenal
script that got turned into a movie and
was made well she didn't learn to read
until she was 14.
wow yeah totally I think it's kind of
earth-shattering how much of that we're
told it has to be this way really
doesn't have to be because that's not
how real life Works in any any capacity
at all correct so it's really
fascinating yeah yeah it very much is we
just again we got to start really trying
to think through what we think we know
and being okay questioning all of the
things we think we know again getting
back to where we're curious right like
that's we need to we need to make that
the standard yeah because the standard
that we have now of like did you get A's
on these five subjects like that doesn't
play out in the real one at all what
really does something my sister and I
were contemplating with my husband were
like what is it that makes an
intelligent person is it someone who
knows really like everything about a
specific subject or is it someone who is
logical and is able to hear different
opinions about something and change
their mind and able to decipher
I don't know it's such an interesting
question like what same question is what
makes a successful person is it somebody
it's not really somebody who just has a
good job because there's so many people
who grew up in the modern system right
God went to college even went to
somewhere like Stanford has this
incredible job makes a ton of money but
are they happy there can be somebody who
makes yeah there can be somebody who
makes fifty thousand dollars a year and
they're way more happy than someone who
has this incredible job I've been I tell
the story all the time I was on a
private you know the first time I was
flown on a private jet I was with the
guy who owned the jet you know the guy's
worth millions upon millions of dollars
and he's crying on the jet because he
hates his life he hated it and then we
landed in this Airfield and I talked to
another guy as the the executive went to
go clean himself up in the bathroom
because he'd been crying because he's
absolutely miserable and hates his life
I spoke to the airplane mechanic who was
40 years old and he was retiring at that
point because he had lived below his
means he'd saved all his money he'd only
ever been in airplane mechanic since he
was 18 he loved every single minute of
it and was it was just the happiest dude
on the planet you know is this like the
the Paradox was just so it was so in
your face and you know uh I think it's
Tony was it Tony Wagner
put him in Tony Wagner who's that but
there's you know people who have done
work on on the various types of
intelligences too right and so that's
that's a thing as well and that's part
goes back to that Unique Kind of DNA
aspect
um you know one of the most
one of the greatest compliments I think
I ever received was actually a principle
that I interviewed uh I was interviewing
for a teaching position that I ended up
getting and the principle that I
interviewed with
she said you know when I walked out of
that interview I felt like you could
you're the type of person that could get
along with uh in-laws inmates and
infants
I love it that is an amazing compliment
yes it was and I thought that was the
coolest thing and I look back on my life
and I go man I do
I do have an ability to get along with
pretty much everybody Under the Sun I
can find something to relate to them I
genuinely enjoy people I genuinely do
love and appreciate them and so uh it's
a very and so is that a specific
intelligence right so because I'm I'm
there's a lot of other ways that I'm
wildly you know incapable and so the
various types of intelligence that's
always interesting too but but that's
also a type of skill on some level would
you say too like yeah so it's a skill
and the example that you can pass on to
your kids and so by being the example of
how you interact with people in the
world and like that would be I think the
number one thing that parents can take
away from this home education thing is
like how are you living your life which
is what I love about everything that
you're sharing yes ma'am yes ma'am it's
the most important part okay so I just
have a couple more questions
um can you address concerns people might
have with homeschoolers not being able
to go to college or get a degree which
obviously is not true but can you just
like explain that to people yeah that's
a really good question I appreciate that
you asked that because that's definitely
one of the things that people have
that's a that's a fear
um so I always start these conversations
again in a number of ways
um one is college
is college worth it right now anyways
you know and I want parents to question
that because again that the narrative
has just been well yeah you get done
with school you go to college and then
college is what
I would say as somebody who was at a
university and somebody who has multiple
graduate degrees I would say college is
actually a net negative for more people
now than it is a positive I actually
very much believe that
um so that aside that's a whole other
conversation is college even worth it is
it even a good idea that aside
College admissions process is also a
game right I use that phrase a lot
there's the game of school there's the
game of there's the game of taxes
there's the game of relationships
there's the game what game do you want
to play
the game that everybody plays isn't
always necessarily the game you want to
play so College admissions is also a
game
each College Plays the game a little
differently and year to year it can
shift a little bit too
one of the things that I like to do to
shake parents up is go well one of the
ways to play the game very easily and to
get into a lot of colleges is actually
to not even have a high school diploma
and they go what they go yeah drop out
of school
drop out if your kid drops out at 16 and
then go uh to a junior college because
most junior colleges you don't even need
a high school diploma go to a junior
college at 16 as an adult and play the
junior college game for two years and
then at 18 you've got an associate's
degree you actually go in and apply as a
an adult transfer student you're going
to most likely be weighted more heavily
than if you were an 18 year old that
just came out of high school with a 4.3
GPA
there's plenty of ways to play the game
some universities
actually prefer home educated students
lots of universities actually have a
separate application process at Stanford
we had a separated application process
for The Homeschool students
interesting yeah
so you had all of your 40 000 students
that were applying the standard way
and we'd play the game with that meaning
well we're Stanford so we can't go above
five percent acceptance rate of these
students otherwise your rankings in the
U.S news and World Report goes down
so it doesn't matter if 15 of them
deserve to be there by the you know the
metrics that are supposedly what allows
you to get into school
five percent boom done
but first and foremost we're looking for
who are the rich people
you're the future donors to Stanford you
can have it 2.3 GPA and Beyond probation
but if Mom and Dad are famous and are
gonna
put a lot of money in welcome to
Stanford University
all right so and then do you fill a need
we need a point guard we need a you know
somebody that swims the 200 IM whatever
like if you fill a need welcome to
Stanford and then we have to take a look
at okay well this year we need uh less
Chinese men and we need more black girls
so that weighs you more heavily welcome
to Stanford right so you're playing all
of these levels before you ever get to
the meritocracy that we're all taught
that it is
every university has a different level
of game that is going on there but at
Stanford oh yeah at the 40 000 over here
oh but we might get 5 000 homeschool
students and we're going to take 25 of
them and the application process looks
different we want to see a digital
portfolio versus a traditional
transcript right so home educated kids
have been going to college forever and
in this day and age it's actually easier
for them to get into a school than it is
if you come from a traditional
environment it's actually easier okay
that's helpful to share and then can you
go into why you think college might not
be the best option for everybody or even
the majority of people yeah there's a
there are a lot of reasons one
um Academia as a whole for a lot of
universities has been taken over by
um
of a political idea so when I say
leftist people get upset and they're
like oh okay well this is Republican no
I'm I'm apolitical I'm not even talking
about politics what I'm talking about is
if Academia is supposed to be something
that allows you to learn how to think
and learn how to who you are but you've
got 95 of your college professors
identifying as far left and they're
coming in with a very specific agenda
you're not being educated you're being
indoctrinated and I wouldn't care if
that was far left if that was Far Right
the point is it shouldn't be about any
kind of ideology it should be about how
to educate the human being right but
that's been subverted by a lot of our
universities unfortunately
there's also the fact that a lot of
professors now get paid based on
Research versus teaching
they're paid to publish
they don't necessarily care about the
educational aspect of it
prices are now through the roof you have
so many people that are going to massive
amounts of debt to come out with a
degree that everybody else has yeah it's
not the same as it was when our parents
not the same as we're going to college
everybody's got a college degree but now
you have a hundred thousand dollars in
debt
to do what really amounts to
the academic work
of what you did in high school it's
really not all that much different and
just longer yeah and and it doesn't
guarantee you any any sort of job
afterwards at all there's a lot of other
Alternatives where you don't have the
opportunity costs where you lose four
five six years of your life wasting a
whole bunch of time you can actually go
into the workforce you can go into an
apprenticeship or an internship in
corporate jobs and and get ahead without
that that debt there's so many other
opportunities now that college ends up
becoming a net negative for so many so
what about for those who want a very
specific job like to be a doctor or a
even a teacher right if there's certain
things that they have to check they have
to play that you have to play the game
right and that the percentage of people
who know that going in is ridiculously
low
it's ridiculously low so true I mean I
went to college as I was like what am I
gonna do I don't know what I'm gonna do
I guess I'll get a business
administration degree because I just
didn't know what I want to do I thought
I better I better go to college and
that's the majority right and I did the
same thing I'm like I guess everybody's
going to college I guess I will and I
got all my Straight A's in college too
and then graduated from college and went
cool still don't know who I am what I'm
good at what what and I I definitely
don't feel like what I learned in
college was something I needed to be
able to do the job that I do today like
I like I literally I didn't need any of
that don't even remember most of it and
most people feel that way the majority
right but yeah are there is there a
small percentage they know they want to
go to med school yes so want to be an
engineer yeah
even engineering there are a lot of
people that go into the engineering
field without an engineering degree and
interesting a lot of Engineers will tell
you I have a good friend who is when I
say he's a good engineer he built his
company up to about a 500 million dollar
a year organization as an engineer so I
mean he's a top-notch world-class
engineer
and he will tell you none of the
engineering courses that he actually
took had anything to do with how he
actually operated it was just playing
the game it didn't transfer to what the
skills were actually needed to use
interesting so there's a difference
there too but
um if you are going to play that game
then go play it as efficiently as you
can meaning don't take on a massive
amount of debt if you don't have to go
do the JC route for a couple years and
save a bunch of money right work on ways
to make it very very economically
feasible for you so that you're not
trapped
in anything you don't have to be trapped
in while you go pursue that thing that
you need to play that game
um you know and understand again
understand the game that you're playing
is some of it is some of it not playing
a game though like if it's like I really
want to learn to be a very specific type
of doctor seems like those types of
degrees are needed and you would learn
so much from that right do you feel that
way or no uh no
um so so what would you say what would
you say is the alternative then so do
you know well there for somebody you
know that wants to go into a very
specific field that requires that degree
there is a no one there's not an
alternative right right I'll try what
would be the best like I'm saying if you
had that ability just have to understand
that you're still gonna have to
self-educate so let me give you an
example right do you know who rob wolf
is no I feel like this whole
conversation like do you know this
person
so so Rob super uh super smart guy
really uh wildly intelligent does a lot
of uh conversations around health and
nutrition and
um you know but it's just he's a super
good dude and he's not dogmatic when it
comes to any of it he's just like look
man Tinkerbell works for you eat real
stuff like yeah super good guy but he uh
has been around for a long time kind of
in this industry and he's been on you
know Rogan's podcast a couple times
written a bunch of books and really
really good dude he was living in the
same
um city that I was getting my Bachelor's
degree in and so I first got turned on
to him I was a Kinesiology major and
that was just because I liked sports
like I didn't have anything I ever
wanted to do with that so
um Kinesiology major I had taken some
nutrition classes you know for the
kinesiology degree and I'm like okay
this is pretty generic kind of stuff I
went to one of Rob's seminars where we
really dove into
Human Performance and the way nutrition
plays in the body and all the different
variables and all this you know
bioavailability and all that all these
things that I had never heard of in my
life taking nutrition courses
I was like this is interesting but what
was most interesting to me was that we
had a number of doctors who were there
who were raising their hand and they're
like we don't know any of this wow we
know none of this
like we're taught more bedside Manner
and pharmacology like what pills are we
prescribing we're not taught this we
take a 30 you know uh uh uh a uh
six-month course you know in nutrition
they're taking the basically the same
stuff I was but then they were going to
be so a lot of these
um professions you know if you want to
be a surgeon yeah then the actual
surgeon like there are some things
you're going to take that are wildly
valuable but you're gonna have so much
fluff and garbage that has nothing to do
without you actually doing
that you're again you're you're stuck in
a game so how do you play that as
quickly and as efficiently as you can
yep and self-educate is kind of like
your core message self educate yep love
it find out what you need to know and
disregard the stuff that you might even
be taught to question it right not
saying just question it dive a little
deeper take a be willing and brave
enough to look at the alternative option
and just consider it yeah not to change
your mind just look at other evidence
too totally and it reminds me of uh the
Ted Talk called hack schooling makes me
happy by Logan laponte and have you
heard of that one okay that does sound
that one sounds familiar yeah it's it's
a young kid so it's not like college age
what we were just talking about but
um basically it just talks about like
how he does life schooling Life
Education personal experience going into
whatever field he is excited about he'll
become an internship uh he'll become an
intern at an internship for whatever
company he's most excited about and if
we can give our kids those resources
they're going to love learning and and
learn so much better by doing it in the
real world which is just like the
responsibility stuff you were talking
about because we can talk to our kids
about how to be how to be safe in the
kitchen right but if we don't let them
actually get in the kitchen then they're
not going to learn how to do it very
well that's not a young age yeah that's
right I love that example too so that's
with the home school group that I have
the home education group that I have
right now that's what our focus is this
month is cooking and chemistry so we've
got you know it's just an emphasis this
month on just like Let Your Heroes get
in the kitchen and start cooking and
learn the knife skills and learn how you
know these different things were like
let's let's do that and that's why you
know when when you're asking about
college there's programs like Praxis
have you ever heard of Praxis Praxis so
if you if anybody listening you go to
discover praxis.com
and practice what they do is it's a six
month uh kind of a boot camp of
transferable skills so it's a boot camp
of self-directed you know learning how
to write ad copy learning how to do blog
posts learning how to do some very basic
coding learning how to do very basic
communication emails things that are
transferable to a lot of different
Industries right you'll do that for six
months do some projects around math
and then you'll go six months you'll
interview and you'll go work full time
six months at usually at a startup but
it's in an industry that you're kind of
excited about and you kind of like
you go take on this role it's a paid
position and it's paid more than the
cost of the program so you come out
with no debt
it's a one-year program versus four or
five years and like 98 of them roll
right into a full-time position with the
average starting salary of 50 Grand a
year amazing that's awesome why would
you not like the opportunity cost
there's no debt yeah you wrote like why
would you not so there's so many
Alternatives like that now too yeah that
again just make the traditional College
route far more unattractive and again
yeah if you want to go to college man go
to college but a lot of times it is an
emotional thing we actually had um
it just popped into my head but we had a
student who at one of my campuses
graduated from high school
and walked off that stage at 18 and was
offered a position with a nationwide
organization
that had up until that point with about
a thousand employees Nationwide up to
that point they had never hired anybody
without a college degree wow they
changed the entire structure to hire
this young man at 18. it's amazing went
in at like a seventy thousand dollar a
year position leading other people
career level job
and his mom said to me oh yeah that's
pretty cool but I still hope he goes to
college and I said okay great how come
well so that he can have that degree to
fall back on so he can get a good job
he has a good job what is that yes what
is this that he has right it's again the
cult mentality the conditioning runs so
deep yeah you really don't think you
have any other option to like live life
this is what everyone's doing so I gotta
do it this way so what are these what do
these campuses you're talking about for
anybody who doesn't know about you and
what you have created yeah I got to
partner with
What's called the actin academies
a-c-t-o-n
um and you know it was I was on a
mission to start my own thing
um and was was building a community
around uh what I thought education
should look like for a group of young
people uh and in doing so I was talking
to a group of professors one of them
said to me you sound like you're
building an acting academy is that what
you're doing I said I have no idea what
you're talking about and said well I
think you have to look it up because it
sounds very similar to what you're doing
so I looked it up and realized there was
a group of entrepreneurs there was only
a couple at the time
who were working together not in a
franchise way in a well I live in North
Carolina Ellen lives in Hawaii we both
feel the same thing about young people
in education we're both trying to build
something and we're just going to bounce
ideas and resources off each other kind
of way so I joined forces with them and
and um you know I launched multiple
schools in California I've now helped
entrepreneurs launch these schools in
multiple countries and in States and so
there's a few hundred acting academies
around the world amazing and can they
just go to actonacademy.com to look
those up they go to if they go to
actonacademy.org.org they can do it yep
then they can do a search
um there and find it but you know if
people don't want to go to a full-blown
campus you know we've helped families
open some of those small co-ops like you
know you were talking about or we help
families home educate the whole point of
it is you have options it's not just oh
kids you're five got to go to school now
for the next you know 13 years
you have options and they can all be
really good options so I want people to
just know that so they can be
intentional about making a choice love
it okay my last question for you what is
your core message you hope to reach
parents with whether they homeschool or
send their kids to compulsory school or
home educate or send their kids to
compulsory school what would you like to
leave them with at the end of this
conversation stop being afraid love that
stop being afraid most humans operate
out of fear
in almost every Arena
and it's because they're not willing to
take action and take responsibility and
they're not willing to question all of
the different games they are playing all
of the different roles they are playing
they're not willing to question is there
something else I can do
and a lot of times there is but it also
means again stepping up in that
responsibility right but they're afraid
stop being afraid it is it is
um
the biggest pandemic epidemic whatever
you want to call it that I that I see in
society love it thank you so much this
has been amazing I could go on and on
with you I feel like it's such an such
an empowering powerful important
conversation to have and I appreciate
everything you're sharing online
everybody go follow his Instagram I
think it's just Matt Boudreaux right
yeah such an amazing such amazing
content you put out there daily
inspiration to help you just take charge
of life and be the best parent you can
be for your kids you're awesome thank
you no honor is mine I appreciate your
message I appreciate your voice I
appreciate everything you do too so it
was a pleasure thank you okay great I
think we're gonna end it here and thanks
everyone for joining
foreign
[Music]